Film Courage: When Millie approached you after
the course in Riverside and said “I’m
so silly, I did this.”
You saw something in her that said well if
the other writers said “I don’t want to
take THE GRAPES OF WRATH and outline it well
then they believe in this romance of being
able to write and I’m just going to sort
of sit down and take a bottle of Scotch and
a cigarette and pound away all of the things
that happened to me.”
Dr. Ken Atchity, author/producer: Right, they’re
in love with image of being a writer.
You know it’s the romance of being a writer,
the struggle, the torment, the agony and the
ecstasy, all of those grandiose concepts that
writers have done to get bigger paydays, you
know that’s all good.
Like I had a writer (who was been a client
for years) a dear friend who we sold like
12 of his screenplays and it took him (honestly)
a week to write a screenplay.
And it took me three years to train him never,
never to admit that.
And so I got him an agent and the agent was
always beating him up and saying “You can’t
say that.
You have to say you need 3 months.
6 months or whatever.
You can’t say you do it in a week.”
They won’t…we’re trying to get a million
dollars for this.”
And the truth is you can do it in a week.
But you can put it aside for two months and
go back and work on it some more and so on.
Because the reality of writing is much easier
than the myth of it.
Walker Percy one of my favorite novelist who
wrote The Last Picture Show said “Perhaps
the secret of speaking is having something
to say."
And that’s what it’s all about, you have
story to tell, then you can tell it, it’s
not a problem.
Just don’t start writing it until you know
the story.
Like you don’t start telling the joke before
you know the joke.
You don’t walk in with 3 by 5 cards and
tell a joke from the 3 by 5 card.
You know the thing by heart and then you tell
it.
It’s not the agony, it doesn’t need to
be the agony and we it doesn’t have the
structure because when you haven’t learned
the mechanics of it like two kinds of productive
writers.
When you learn the mechanics then you can
be happy.
And you can do it whenever you want to do
it.
Like any writer who knows it will tell you
they can write on trains, busses, planes,
they can write standing up, sitting down.
I had a dear friend my client for years Nancy
Friedman who wrote on her back for the last
10 years of her life because she couldn’t
sit up and she couldn’t stand up and so
she wrote on her back and she just kept writing
books.
And the writing is easier if you know what
you’re doing.
And whether it’s Harlan Ellison or Ray Bradbury,
they’ll all tell you the same thing.
But when you think it’s this huge agony
and it is (like Virginia Woolf and so on),
she’s never figured it out, that’s why.
She’s believed that it has to be an agony
to be good.
And I don’t think Shakespeare was in agony.
I think he was just dashing this stuff off
as fast as he could write because he was reading
everything that was coming from Italy and
you know South of Europe and stealing it like
crazy, redoing it, copying it, he heard stories
all around and he just couldn’t wait before
going to the pub and after going to the pub
to sit down and dash it off.
And he revised, he spent a lot of time revising.
We know that from the folios but it’s not
the living in the garret starving thing that
has to happen at all.
It’s just figuring out what you’re doing.
It’s a craft, you know, it’s a craft that
has to be learned.
And the art comes in, there are brilliant
people who do the craft and there are not
so brilliant people who do the craft.
So there is plenty of room for art but it
doesn’t have to be cutting your ear off
kind of thing.